each and every one of you I'm gonna be
putting back into this prison you are
the first 12 to get this business going
it's not about pissing around with
glitter this is real and it's gonna get
tougher
we're running your business you're gonna
learn yeah you're gonna earn I'm gonna
put back inside to this prison how's
that let you feel great
well now I can't wait to start Grafton
you know on it again in the kitchen
start cooking a lot of these prisoners
we all need tough love it's like the
love your mom will give you I remember
we're in prison we need to be bloody
told off this is my first day teaching
the bad boys Brigade to get more done
I've radically changed these prisoners
routine they're eating in the kitchen
not in their cells
the guys will lock up here they know
they know when they're gonna get out
there so they know what time they're
going to be locked up any change to that
it messes the system up messes were
there when things change I spent when
things start going wrong sure enough
just the idea of change has sent
Lawrence Gibbons off on one he's thrown
a hissy fit it wants to eat in his cell
where it keeps his tomato sauce
resources slow there we are let's just
calm down it I can Whitman Flores yeah
Jose you done completely well that's it
did you you take him back to the wind
losing Lawrence is bad enough but his
walk out spreads dissent in the ranks
it's like a blank record with not much
teamwork going on here what's your soup
sweet food I don't understand they still
realities the biggest entry [ __ ] it it's
gonna be a [ __ ] I don't get a chance to
say what you say but you're still making
a little appreciate the wings okay Lisa
another we'll stop arguing that wanted
it listens a big difference between
talking to each other and shouting each
other is talk nicely and let's remember
we're a team as soon as their routine
and the minute you change one little
thing
bang I like a bunch of [ __ ] babies
you know just realizing what a sham is
this so-called Brigade is turning out to
be 20 yearsI I got dealt a dysfunctional
cars
my little brother became a heroin addict
and my father became an alcoholic
designs range from disastrous
[ __ ] noses gotta go inside the bag
you know you didn't have to the
delectable